j'en parle avec isabelle dostaler et les
doyenne de la faculté d'administration
des affaires à l'université mémorial de
terre-neuve
merci beaucoup d'être là madame de staël
r ça fait plaisir
on l'a surnommée la reine des airs cet
avion là expliquez nous ce qu il admis
tic cet appareil mais sa taille et sa
construit contribuez vous quoi
démocratiser le transport aérien il ya
plus de cinquante ans déjà qu'on le
conte le mettait en service
puis comme ça permettait de mettre plus
de gens à bord ça permettait de diminuer
le coût d'exploitation font le coût par
passager donc donc le prix du billet
alors si tu n'es pas qui se termine
c'est sûr que ça fera pas plus
l'imaginaire c'est donc ça arrive en ce
moment qui on l'a tellement d'annonce
qui sont plus ou moins qui sont assez
négative au fond ce qui a trait au
transport aérien
on dirait que ça frappe un peu plus mais
il faut se rappeler quand même que
c'était une mise au rancart si on veut
donc certains transporteurs du moins le
quitter qui était prévu donc non mais
c'est ce que certains oui c'est ça c'est
pas de vent c'est donc par là le
contexte actuel d'environ six mois
je ne sais pas c'est pas plusieurs
années mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
sait quelque chose qu'on prévoyait qu'il
a c'est sûr écouter on se cache europol
ça va tellement mal que ben la chose à
faire et est de faire cette chose le
plus rapidement et d'aller bompard qui
ces avions dans le désert et on veut
juger le gisti pour les pièces et c'est
évidemment avant qu'on ait terminé
complètement de l'utiliser mon qantas se
cesse de les utiliser maintenant il
reste une poignée lormont près d'autres
transporteurs dans le monde mais c'est
encore aujourd'hui un symbole de
nostalgie 7,47 du bon vieux temps de
l'aviation se paie le luxe s'était le
plaisir à l'occasion sa bien changé oui
c'était le luxe le plaisir et l'on sait
que c'est plus tellement c'est un moins
de tricot vite la moins d'avoir
la possibilité de voyager en classe
affaires ou en classe ou en première
classe c'est sûr que si rien de très
agréable de son passé davantage à
l'intérieur des appareils fait qu'on a
l'impression qu'on avait plus de place
même chose du côté du 380 et en ce très
grand conseil sur lequel airbus avait
misé ebook ou du canton on on s'inquiète
toujours qu'ils ont bon on parle toute
la question de bombardier bbd
à quel point le développement
aéronautique s'accrocherait ou qu'il
perde de l'argent mais le 380 on saura
jamais vraiment combien ça coûte et est
ce que est ce que est ce qu'on veut
c'est rentré dans son argent ou pas
c'est un site instinct c'est un grand
mystère alors ça aussi la mise aux
remparts de cet appareil
et puis l'autre chose que je me dis ici
par delà l'aspect au delà de l'aspect
note nostalgique je me demande ce que ça
veut dire quant à toute cette
organisation du transport aérien autour
de la plaque tournante dans ce qu'on
appelle en anglais
robben sport où on a même des passagers
des régions à travers avec des appareils
plus petits on les amène à l'aéroport
centrale ou aéroport principal de la
compagnie aérienne et là on agglomère
les gens dans les plus grands appareils
pour les amener outre-mer on se demande
ce sont des robots plus tôt arrivé ce
qu'on appelle en anglais l'europe bull
sitting ou on passe simplement par
dessus le hub et quand on pense à notre
notre fameux cseries qui sera connu sous
le nom de à 220 c'est un plus petit
appareil ça apparaît qu'une bonne portée
qui pourrait très bien amené des groupes
de gens plus petits plus début petit
groupe de gens vers des destinations
internationales à partir d'aéroports
plus plus régionaux tout c'est pourquoi
on fait ça madame dostaler fait que les
voyageurs ne veulent plus faire de
correspondance ou c'est parce que du
point de vue des transporteurs c'est
plus rentable c'est quoi la logique
derrière ça c'est des appareils qui sont
chers à opérer un qui sont en danger et
énergivore ils sont lourds a lancé ce
que on va demander ma
plus léger pour valverde appareil plus
petit parce qu'ils consomment consomme
moins consomme moins d'énergie en même
temps pourquoi on fait ce fait il faut
pas toujours s'imaginer que les valeurs
qu'elle une décision d'affaires sont si
rationnelle que ça on parle toujours de
on utilise ce terme disons monfils pour
expliquer un peu à quel point les
entreprises se copient les uns les
autres et bompard un bon moment le
modèle perçu comme gagnant ça a été
celui du label sport de la plaque
tournante et si le modèle que les
marchés financiers ni plus ni moins
voulait bien voir les compagnies
aériennes utilisé c'est un modèle qu'on
a dû créer parce que on faisait pas ça
la halle à des règlementations ce
transport aérien là autant de la
réglementation toutes étaient
centralisées la décision de mettre tel
appareil sur telle route une décision à
la limite peu gouvernementales alors une
fois que on laisse aller le libre marché
on se dit ok comment on va faire pour
coordonner tout ça alors c'est ce
système de robes en stock qui était
perçu finalement comme le le moyen le
plus efficace de transporter des gens de
régions éloignées de leur donner accès à
un réseau transport international à des
destinations internationales de la façon
la plus économique je ne suis pas en
train de dire que ça va disparaître
parce qu'on a on note quand on a vu
l'avènement des locaux ce quart uruguay
en scooter au rabais et biz années 80
qui bon qui voyagent et qui se promenait
des aéroports secondaires en aéroport
secondaire
on pensait que c'en était fini de la
place la plaque tournante et avec
l'arrivée du 380 le traitement airbus
était comme un vote de confiance pour
pour la plaque on entendrait ce que on a
le sang chaud
le locking c'est ça bon avec la fin du
set 47 l'arrêt du a380
looking des grands avions comme ça est
terminé c'est quoi l'avion du futur
bah écoutez moi je pense qu'avec avec ce
qui se passe en ce moment
quelle grande période de questionnement
non seulement ça va excessivement mal
mais aussi on va se dire bon est-ce que
c'est plus dans de transporter autant de
monde en même temps donc c'est là où un
plus petit appareil comme la série comme
la halle 220 pourrait créer de très
agréables surprises dans les années à
venir mais tout ça tout ça dépend aussi
de ce qui va il a bien que son départ
l'aviation d'affaires juste en terminant
madame de staël air bon c'est le modèle
de bombarder maintenant est ce que ça
peut être payant
ça pourrait l'être on pourrait
exactement faire le même calcul des
avions de ligne plus petit oui mais
d'autre part peut-être que la ville que
l'avion d'affaires va être attirant pour
pour les voyageurs en même temps tout ça
ça veut dire que le transport aérien
sera peut-être bien moins démocratiques
dans l'est dans les prochaines années et
ce sera autre chose qui sera réservé
pour pour ceux qui pourront se le jeu le
permettent un plutôt que cette idée de
s'entasser à plusieurs dans une cabine
et on compte sur vous pour surveiller
cette grande transformation madame de
staël air merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
ça m'a fait plaisir